BGM
あーあっ
バタン
やっべ…
こんにちはじめしゃちょーです
直そう
皆さんシーブリーズってしってるかい？
まあ僕も中学校の時はお世話になったんだけれども
部活とかねスポーツをしていると汗をかくんだよ
その時こう制汗剤とかで、使ってた
シーブリーズっていう商品があるんだけども
今回シーブリーズのシリーズのボディシャンプーがあるんですけども
そのシーブリーズのスーパークルボディシャンプーっていうのがあるんですけれども
こちら
俺が中学校の時はシーブリーズをしてないやつはだめだったっていうくらいお世話になっております
シーブリーズさんありがとうございます
そうシーブリーズのスーパークールドボディシャンプーっていうのがあるんだけれども
このスーパクールボディシャンプーを使うと
真夏の環境でも涼しく感じるという
画期的なアイテムでらしいでござるよ
ちなみに説明しておくと、シーブリーズ実は１００年も続いている歴史的なブランドだよ
１９０２年から実はシーブリーズは始まっているのだよ
今回スーパークルボディシャンプーがですね、真夏の環境でもこれを使ったら涼しく感じるらしいので
♪BGM
どうなの？まさかねまだちょっと、気温的には、そんなに暑くない今日この頃
そこで、僕は考えた
いっそのこと僕自身でも真夏の環境を作り出そうと
ちょっとまだ真夏の季節じゃないんで
今日はですねこちらの部屋を頑張って
真夏の気温ぐらいまでがん上げします
で、そこで、俺らの中学校の頃みたいにね部活をします
バスケットのつもりね
部活をしてチョー汗かいて
その時の気分を感じます
真夏で運動している気分を味わう
いつもとうり運動して僕は
どんな気持ちになるか
嫌な気持ちですよね
暑い気持ちになるんですけれども
そのあとすぐにシャワーを浴びてきます
シャワーを浴びる時に
スーパークールドライシャンプーを使って
また真夏の環境に戻ってきますその時
俺はどう感じるかです
使う前と使った後
の感じをね比較してみようと思います
行くぜ
風速マックス
温度３１度
今暖房効き始めているので
ちょっと環境があったかくなってきてますでは、では、あったまるまでしばしお待ちを
僕はアツアツのうどんを作ってきます
♪BGM
うわーアッツ
なんかもう真夏の体育館を思い出すよ
アツアツと辛い調味料の入れたうどんを、持ってきました
苦しいということで、実験スタートでございます
運動しまっくたり、熱いもの食ってしてめっちゃ汗かいて
苦しい状態そう、スーパークール
を使った後を比較していきたいと思います
♪BGM
素振り素振り
♪ｂｇｍと、シュシュという口で出した音
ぜあー
（ＢＧＭと素振りの効果音）
割ときついぜ
うどんをすする音
アー熱い
ｂｇｍと、刀の、空気抵抗の音
１，２，３，４，５うどん
♪うどんをすする音
まだ足りねえ
必殺
（突き刺しの効果音）
ｂｇｍと、様々な運動の効果音
しゅーりょー
もうごめんなさい限界でございます。これだけ汗をかきました
こんなもんですよ夏のスポーツとかっ夏っててものは
俺は、ずっと、バスケ部だったから夏の苦しさってもんはわかる
はい、そこで君たちは、思っただろう
俺は今汗臭いと思っただろう
いいだろう。ホントは、いつもならさせをかいてる状態なら汗臭いです
ただね僕はこの運動する前にね
シーブリーズのボディシャンプークール＆デオドラント
こちらですね。こちらの商品を使っていたので
臭くないです
これでね事前に体を洗っておくことで、汗のにおいをしっかり抑えてすっきり爽快感が持続するボディシャンプーなので
これをね、運動とか夏の暑い日に外に出る前にこれで体を、洗っておくと
汗のにおいがしないというなので僕は今いい匂いがします
早速ですねスーパークールボディシャンプーを使って体を洗ってきます。純粋に…なんか
汗が嫌なんで…洗ってきまーす
ガチャ
水の流れる音
キャー！
あっ
えーあんまり暑いって、かんじないっす
さっきと全然違う
凄い！スーパークールは、結構効き目がありました
なんかね、体がなんかすーすーするんだよね
触れる空気が暑くないっていうか
スーパークールを使った後に扇風機を使うとなんかもっと、涼しいっていうか寒いぐらい涼しいって聞いたので
使ってみます。おっおすーすーする。寒い
はいって言うことでシーブリーズの
スーパークールボディシャンプーとシーブリーズボディシャンプークール＆デオドラントでございました
お出かけする前にクール＆デオドラントで体を洗って
出て
汗かいて、暑いとこから帰ってきたりしたらスーパークールボディシャンプーで体を冷やすと
この二つあれば多分
夏は、結構…行ける気がします
部活をしている君とかたくさん動かなくちゃいけないしなくちゃいけない人とか
ぜひシーブリーズお試しくだされ
とりあえず今涼しいんだけど運動してオラ、疲れちゃたよ
がんばってシーブリーズで夏を乗り切ろう
じゃあな
エンディング